they think they've now got the upper
hand in this protracted conflict but the
rebel fighters have been celebrating
their advance into zuria have been
driven back before and this is a city
that the Gaddafi regime will be
desperate to retain most of these
fighters had spent weeks in the
mountains regrouping before staging
their assault on Saturday they've taken
casualties government ciphers are still
holding positions within the city but
the rebels claim to be in control of
Central's aware Colonel Gaddafi's
response has been a rare but defiant TV
address though only his voice was heard
what they resist take up your weapon on
with the fighting to liberate Libya from
the traitors get ready for the fight get
ready for the Million Man March to clean
up the land the land of purity the land
of our grandparents our fathers doesn't
allow absolutely then after weeks of
stalemate the weekend has seen major
gains for the rebels they claim to have
taken control of the southern city of
Gary an and crucially have cut the
regime's supply route to the west of
Tripoli fierce fighting has been taking
place in sermon on the outskirts of
subrata as well as a we're all three
towns lie on the main coast road to
Tunisia and with NATO bombing torans
Lytton over the weekend the attacks on
Tripoli are from all sides those NATO
missions have played an important part
in helping the rebels move forward this
bombing raid by Tornado aircraft from
raf marham was aimed at taking out
command facilities and air defenses the
fighting arounds aware is already having
an impact on the border with Tunisia 100
miles to the west two days ago this was
bustling with cars and trucks taking
much-needed supplies to Tripoli I've
been allowed to come up to the no-man's
land between the Tunisian and Libyan
borders just to have a look for myself
to see what is going on even though we
are not
to bring our camera up here so I'm just
recording this on my phone but the
crossing is absolutely deserted and
there appears to be some cars who tried
to get through let me turn back Rizzoli
what the reason was given for the bean
turn back they told us they've got the
subrata but have been told to turn back
by government soldiers because it was
too dangerous for the moment Gaddafi has
been isolated but is still a long way
from being defeated in woods sky news on
the Libya Tunisian border